It's a
PlayStation 4 It's
designed so that you can't see the screw from anywhere, and you
can see the view to age only on this back side.
The screw is also covered with a seal.
Disassemble  First, remove this screw.
Two of the seals are made of open-prevention tape.
Problem 1
You can see it later when you disassemble it. There
are only four screws.
Loosen the maintenance.
Four screws.
You can remove the outer cover underneath by
loosening
it. It's a leaf.
There's a heat sink in this area. This is an optical disk drive
that supports both dvd and bd.
This part is the power supply.
It
's very unwieldy if there is another power supply unit at the user's place, so
we try to put it in the set as much as possible and integrate it.
Remove the stable. This is
the bluetooth antenna.  Remove the optical disk drive unit Remove
the lid at the hard disk drive unit
To remove the hard disk, just loosen one 20
lag hard disk drive
This hard disk is 500 gb and
can be replaced with a commercially available large capacity one
Next, remove the top cover and you
will see the mingi plate.
Next, remove the leaf spring that secures the heat sink.
Remove the field plate
to say the main board.
Next, remove the
main board. This is the main board.
The cpu core
is x86, which is used in general pc, but it
is specially designed for game consoles to fit in the size of this board.
Here, cpu and gpu are integrated into one chip.  This is the processor.
There are a total of 16 gddr 5 memories, 8 on the front and 8 on the back around the main processor
.
8 gb in total
Bandwidth is 176 gb Persec
gpu requires a lot of bandwidth so we gddr 5  It is
equipped with a dedicated secondary processor to continue network processing with low power consumption even in
the standby state.
The i-fi antenna is
made with 2 patterns on the board here and here.
This is the
usb 3.0 connector to connect the usb device.
This is the aux connector
to connect the PlayStation camera. This is the gigabit ether to connect the network
device.
This is to connect to the av device with the 1 dmi connector. This is
to connect to the audio ank etc. with the glowing audio out.
Next
, remove the other shield plate.
This shield plate has a
heat sink.
This heat sink
uses two heat pipes.
Finally, remove
the fan. This fan has an extension of 85mm in diameter and it will be yesterday.
All shapes are specially designed for ps 4
Finally, this
is the main frame that is a good skeleton. When
all of this is assembled, the press low floor is completed.